advice for writers coming out of college
what do they mean maybe they've been
told you're amazing you're going to set
the world on fire you're going to leave
our little school good luck and they I
would say that my biggest is by two
riders coming out of college is live
your life like when writers will go
straight from college to the writers
room and not experience life then I find
that they are stunted and so I mean for
me personally I like the writer that
explores another career path and then
comes in to the writing and succeeds or
fails miserably and have something to
say like that to me is more interesting
than the writer who got straight A's all
the way through school and then goes
into the writers room so I think the
biggest thing is understand the journey
as well understands that it's not about
selling that first fret it's about
creating longevity and it's about really
taking the time to grow into your own
skin understand who you are what you
have to say and the impact that you want
to make on the world with your writing
so then let's suppose maybe there are
several years out of college and they
finally say you know I'm going to block
out this much time to write this amazing
script what should I start writing about
so I do a horror films as I know those
are popular with the 1834 demographic
and I know I can you know add a
soundtrack to it and I would say right
about what you're the most passionate
about you have to recognize that
the number one thing that sells is
passion and so genre as much as you can
say well yes this genre sells more than
that genre and the timing for this genre
might be better if your passion isn't
there it will show up on the page and
and I think if there were an exact
science as to what will hit then writers
would be making it all over the place I
think really like I'm going to tell you
from being a studio executive for the
number of years that I was and still
being a writing instructor at NBC and
studying pilots in knowing that you know
Hollywood doesn't know exactly what's
going to hit like they're throwing it
out there and praying that middle
America is going to show up and and you
can have you know I think if you were to
survey a bunch of studio executives at
the beginning of each season and say
what shows do you think are going to be
the breakout hit vs what shows are
theirs you know it's hit or miss so
going back to this writer coming out of
college and they say I love lost and i'm
going to write another version of it but
that's not what their story their own
personal stories anything like right and
you kind of get to know this person you
find out they had a totally different
life from i mean you know being on an
island is not maybe something that most
people have but you know something
that's very dissimilar to what they want
to write about what do you say i always
say the biggest thing to write right now
is something that connects your
emotional truth so if you are dying to
write something that has no links to
your emotional truth then think of why
you're passionate about the concept
and maybe move for like I've helped
writers think of personal stories that
they didn't realize actually big connect
to the concept you know so I think it's
really I definitely think that there are
writers who function better writing
about things that are removed from them
but what you have to think about like
say when you take a cherry potter you've
ground it in somatic emotion in the idea
of you know what it what does ground the
concept and those are themes of you know
childhood and coming into your own and
things that we all connect with on a
massive level like when i covered the
4400 i remember thinking okay well not
many of us are going to relate with 4400
who are abducted from Earth and then
returned back to a life that moved on
but what we identify with is abandonment
of redefining your life the idea of
failure to reconnect with the family
that has moved on there are all those
things we connect with so I think when
you're writing stories that are outside
your emotional truth figuring out how to
blend them so that even though the
concept may be way outside anything you
know the emotion and the themes are
connected to you